Speaker 1: 2024 candidate Donald Trump went
to East Palestine, Ohio yesterday and held
an event.
The event was completely deranged.
Trump talked about football.
Trump brought Trump water.
He went to a McDonald's.
He told people to have fun, and the entire
event was a complete and total farce that
went horribly wrong right away.
In this first clip, Trump falsely claims that
the Biden administration intends to do nothing
about what took place in Ohio, but that his
presence there got them to all of a sudden
start doing things.
Speaker 2: That's what it is.
This is really America right here.
We're standing in America.
Unfortunately, as you know, in too many cases,
your goodness and perseverance were met with
indifference and betrayal in some cases.
Biden and FEMA said they would not send federal
aid to East Palestine under any circumstance.
They're not going to send aid.
I just thought that was a strange statement
because I've been working with FEMA for a
long time, for years, and they were great
with us with the tornadoes, the hurricanes
and things like this.
And it was a strange statement to come out
And they were doing nothing for you.
They were.
Intending to do absolutely nothing for you.
J.D. and I spoke and they said they're not
coming.
They're not going to come.
And I said, That's very strange.
FEMA said specifically, this doesn't meet
the criteria and that's horrible.
And somebody has to do something for those
people.
I said back when I announced that I was coming,
they changed their tune.
It was an amazing phenomena.
The mayor and I were discussing that.
It was quite amazing what happened.
Yeah, they said that we can't let this happen.
It was a big change face.
J.D.
Did you ever see a change like that running?
That was a quick yeah.
Speaker 1: As you know, of course, Trump has
an unblemished record as the beacon of corporate
responsibility and is just the perfect person
to really turn to on this issue and hold big
corporations accountable.
Now, nothing that he's saying there is true,
but he does have to make himself the center
of attention.
Trump also says that he brought Trump water
for people, even though when we research it,
it seems like Trump water hasn't actually
been a thing for a very long time.
But what it seems like it is, is Trump gets
labels for some other water and just puts
them on.
It's all crazy.
But he says he brought Trump water for people
in East Palestine, but he also brought like
lower quality water for them as well.
In case some people don't want the great water,
I guess I don't know.
Speaker 2: Especially thank some of the incredible
people that helped us because we're bringing
thousands of bottle of water.
Trump Water actually cross-border some of
it.
We had to go to a much lesser quality water.
You want to get those Trump bottles, I think
more than anybody else.
But we're bringing a lot of help.
Speaker 1: He brought good water and he also
brought lower quality water for people.
Absolutely beyond parody.
The reality, of course, in terms of Trump's
record on train regulations is that there
were safety rules put in place by the Obama
administration for high hazard cargo trains,
which Trump then said, Oh, Obama did that.
I'm now yes, Obama.
Then I'm going to go ahead and repeal those.
And that is exactly what took place.
Trump then started ranting about football,
if you can believe it.
Speaker 2: You know, remind me a little bit.
I don't know if you remember when Ohio State
was going to be playing football for another
season.
They were going to sit back and watch with
the China virus or COVID, whatever you want
to call it.
And I called the head of the Big Ten, Big
Ten football.
He said, you got to get this football open.
And they were great.
They responded and Ohio State played that
season.
Speaker 1: Now, the Big Ten denies that Trump
had any involvement in this, but it is one
of those stories that Trump loves to repeat.
Speaker 2: Nobody remembers that, I think.
Right.
Does anybody?
Speaker 1: Because it didn't happen.
Speaker 2: You know, And you got at least
one at least one you could be close to.
And by now you still would be close, probably.
But we got that open very early.
And you had a great season of football.
Yep.
Speaker 1: All thanks to Trump, of course.
And then lastly, even though Trump is obese,
he makes a fat joke about East Palestine.
Mayor Trent Conaway saying that he's very
easy to find because he's overweight.
Right.
So how could you possibly miss him?
Speaker 2: I also want to recognize a man
who has been working tirelessly for this community
since the beginning of the nightmare.
And Trent, where's Trent?
He's very easy to find, huh?
Speaker 1: Yeah, it it I do think Trump doesn't
see himself as obese because he so frequently
talks about other people's weight and size
while claiming to be six three and weighing
only 239, which, uh, oh God, what is happening
in this country?
So anyway, there is Trump's very inspiring
visit to East Palestine, taking credit for
things he didn't do.
Ignoring his own role in reducing train regulations,
calling the mayor fat and then going to McDonald's
and, I don't know, handing out MAGA hats as
he did.
Another horrible embarrassment.
You can find these clips if you're morbidly
curious about what this all looked like.
We'll have these clips up on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram
for David Pakman show.
They'll be on Facebook at Facebook.com slash
The David Pakman Show.
And of course, on the YouTube channel at YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show.
One of our sponsors is Little Spoon your one
stop shop for healthy, easy meals and snacks
for your baby toddler or big kid delivered
right to your door.
Little spoon has you covered with fresh, organic
baby food for every stage they have toddler
and kids meals that even the picky eaters
will love.
They have smoothies for on the go.
And they just launched a new product called
Biter Balls, which are early finger food meals
cut into bite sizes for easy self-feeding,
which will make your transition to the table
food a breeze.
Little spoons.
Baby food is 100% organic and cold pressed
for every eating stage.
My daughter loves those for toddlers and big
kids.
Little Spoon has the classics like Mac and
Cheese, but they'll sneak things in like butternut
squash and carrots.
They're all kid approved and packed with nutrients.
And the best part, kids meals are under $6
each, baby food under $3 a serving.
So it's quick, easy and affordable.
Go to little spoon dot com and you'll get
50% off your first order with the code Packman
50 off.
The link is down below.